sono qui per deludere questa
presentazione
intanto scusate la voce è la mia sono
ora il mondo appunto e faccio il comico
e d'altronde vi rendete conto da soli
che con il fisico che mi ritrovo solo
due cose potevo farne la vita o il
comico o il nano nei film porno e
purtroppo faccio il comico per la
precisione faccio il comico satirico la
differenza tra comicità e satira è
presto detta comicità e scivolare su una
buccia di banana satire scivolare su un
preservativo usato come dire l'effetto è
lo stesso si ride uguale ma nel secondo
caso fa più schifo questa la differenza
tra comicità e satira
voi chiedete che cosa ci fa a questo
punto un comico satirico ad una ted
conference peraltro di dubbio gusto
visto che in soltanto un minuto di per
conferenza ho già fatto due riferimenti
sessuali piuttosto espliciti e bene ve
lo svelo rapidamente il curatore di
questa conferenza
riccardo staglianò ha deciso in qualche
modo di animare un po la situazione
conferenziale preparando un quiz in
questa ted che è appunto trova l'intruso
e io sono la risposta esatta a questo
quiz ma per rendere la risposta meno
facile meno un banale tentato di
dissimulare questa cosa esponendo
anch'io le mie idee sul tema della
disuguaglianza d'altronde la satira
l'umorismo specie quello satirico si è
spesso espresso sulle sulle
disuguaglianze sulle ingiustizie ea
maggior ragione lo fa e lo deve fare
adesso adesso che da qualche mese tutto
il mondo ha dichiarato gesù charlie no
improvvisamente anche alle più alte
sfere improvvisamente il mondo si dice
incarnato e e volente nell incarnarsi
nella satira chieda la satira di
esprimersi e d'altronde c'è una risposta
anzi due risposte a questa necessità da
parte del mondo ricercare risposte nella
satira nell'umorismo perché perché prima
di tutto le altre categorie hanno
fallito poi avete visto che veniamo no
da anni di crisi in qualche modo che
nessuno
era riuscito realmente ad anticipare
adesso gli ultimi dati e la banca
mondiale confermano la crisi è finita e
la vita che una merda quindi dobbiamo in
qualche modo cercare nuove per nove
persone che sappiano darci delle
previsioni più giuste gli economisti
hanno fallito i sociologi hanno fallito
i metereologi hanno fallito oggi davano
bel tempo e caldo
dunque adesso il mondo si rivolge ai
comici satirici come mai proprio si
cercano risposte nella satira perché ha
dato non lo vedete viviamo in un mondo
sempre più estremo grottesco e
paradossale che cosa c'è di più estremo
grottesco e paradossale della satira
quindi io quest'oggi esprimerò il mio
punto di vista perché poi spesso e
volentieri la satira si riduce a questo
al punto da un punto di vista sulle
disuguaglianze per quanto mi riguarda
per quello che penso io
la disuguaglianza che da sempre più
affligge l'umanità è quella fra persone
alte e persone basse ma già che
ringrazio i nani in sala che esprimono
solidarietà ma già che non siamo qui per
tenere una conferenza sulle dimensioni
del mio membro sessuale mi concentrerò
su altre disuguaglianze che affliggono
l'umanità ce ne sono tantissime le
disuguaglianze economiche sociali
alimentari partiamo da quelle economiche
questo questa disuguaglianza qui
voi sapete nel mondo oggi i ricchi sono
sempre più ricchi ei poveri sono sempre
più poveri ma soprattutto il dato è che
i poveri sono sempre di più
picchi sempre di meno ora nella vulgata
i poveri fanno la figura dei buoni e i
ricchi la figura dei cattivi signori da
questo dato i poveri sempre di più i
ricchi sempre di meno a me sembra che
sono i ricchi le vittime signori i
ricchi si stanno estinguendo come i
dinosauri
noi dobbiamo dichiarare i ricchi una
specie protetta come i panda
dobbiamo difendere i ricchi impedire che
la gente gli dia la caccia e soprattutto
dobbiamo favorire le condizioni
riproduttive per i ricchi i ricchi
devono accoppiarsi di più per
moltiplicarsi noi dobbiamo favorire le
condizioni riproduttive dei ricchi e
questa la sfida del nuovo millennio e
non è una sfida facile attenzione perché
non è facile aver voglia di riprodursi
con un ricco non è il ricco
effettivamente non solletica il nostro
istinto riproduttivo
ma noi dobbiamo fare in modo che i
ricchi non si e stimo dobbiamo fare lo
sforzo di accoppiarsi con i ricchi
solo così diminuirà la disuguaglianza
fra ricchi e poveri ma purtroppo non è
l'unica disuguaglianza che esiste al
mondo vi sono anche altri su guai anze
come quella quel come quella fra uomo e
donna
voi sapete perfettamente che esistono
ancora oggi nonostante gli uomini e le
donne si trovino al mondo da sempre
ancora hanno superato queste
disuguaglianze sono differenze forty se
fra uomini e donne che anche quando
resti al buio non si cancellano
voi sapete che gli uomini trovano lavoro
molto più facilmente delle donne gli
uomini vengono pagati molto di più di
una donna parità di lavoro e gli uomini
fanno molta più carriera di una donna
pensate che persino abortire più facile
per un uomo che per una donna
questa battuta e nonsense ma d'altronde
la discriminazione fra l'uomo e la donna
e non senza quindi non potevo che fare
una battuta non sense al riguardo ma non
solo
discriminazione fra uomini e donne cioè
esiste addirittura un e scream in azione
sulle sugli orientamenti sessuali
voi sapete che una coppia eterosessuale
costituisce famiglia una coppia
omosessuale invece no perché questa
disuguaglianza perché una coppia
omosessuale non può costituire famiglia
mentre una coppia eterosessuale
sì attenzione non vorrei essere
frainteso quello che sto dicendo non è
che dobbiamo riconoscere anche alle
coppie omosessuali di essere famiglia ma
toglie lo statuto di famiglia anche alle
coppie eterosessuali
eliminiamo la famiglia la più grande
fonte di disuguaglianza l'abbiamo vista
anche oggi vedo che applaudire la sento
ma chi ha voglia domani di andare a
pranzo in famiglia che sia è per uomo ma
chi la voglia di passare le domeniche a
pranzo in famiglia
eliminiamo la famiglia la fonte primaria
di raccomandazioni e quindi di
disuguaglianze eliminiamo la famiglia e
sarà un mondo con molte meno
disuguaglianze
certo non avremmo ancora risolto tutte
le disuguaglianze di questo pianeta
ne esistono ancora delle altre le
disuguaglianze alimentari
voi sapete infatti che noi siamo in un
mondo dove moltissime persone muoiono di
fame mentre altre persone giocano con il
cibo rispetto alle quali poi ci sono
appunto persone che si mangerebbero per
fini giocattolino pur di colmare questa
loro fame e attenzione perché questa
situazione disuguaglianza alimentare che
già affligge l'umanità tenderà nei
prossimi anni ad aumentare secondo la
fao infatti avete presente la fao il più
grande catering al mondo la fao
secondo la fao nel 2050 sul pianeta
passeremo da 7 a 9 miliardi cioè più di
troppi attenzione vi farei non vorrei
fare il catastrofista vediamo anche il
lato positivo della cosa
nel giro di trent'anni noi passeremo da
7 a 9 miliardi vuol dire comunque nei
prossimi 30 anni si scoprirà parecchio
questo è sicuramente il lato positivo
della cosa penso spero riguardi anche me
ma il lato negativo è che nel 2050
avremo esaurito gran parte delle risorse
alimentari mentre le altre
scarseggeranno non ci sarà più da
mangiare per tutti e anche nei paesi più
industrializzati come il nostro
passeremo dalla fame nervosa ad essere
nervosi dalla fame
quindi secondo la fao dal 2050 saremo
tutti quanti costretti a mangiare
insetti noi fra qualche anno
mangeremo insetti in alcuni ristoranti
già lo facciamo a nostra insaputa
ma tra 30 anni saremo costretti a
ordinarsi non vogliamo prendere in
considerazione nemmeno per un attimo
l'ipotesi del cannibalismo vaio di chi
vi fa più schifo uno scarafaggio me
guardatevi davvero bene non sarò
occupabile ma commestibile ci mangi poco
per un pasto leggero te lo fa mangiarci
guardate che non vi sto proponendo
niente di così assurdo esistono casi
documentati di cannibalismo nel genere
umano presso certe popolazioni o durante
le carestie o in case di sopravvivenza
mi ricordo il disastro no aereo sulle
ande
il film alive vi ricordate si mangiarono
tra di loro inoltre esistono prove che
il cannibalismo fosse pratica consueta
presso l'uomo sapiens
ed è solo con l'avvento dell'homo
sapiens sapiens che si smise di
praticare il cannibalismo e il fatto che
l'uomo sapiens fosse cannibale mentre
l'uomo sapiens sapiens no dimostra che
se ci pensi il cannibalismo non è poi
così male e solo se ci pensi troppo che
comincia a farti schifo
e se ci pensate ma non troppo mi
raccomando con il cannibalismo non solo
risolviamo il problema della fame nel
mondo ma anche il problema del
sovraffollamento del pianeta bingo così
non solo avremo ancora da mangiare ma
ogni volta che usciremo fuori a cena
troveremo anche parcheggio perfetto
perfetto questa idea
lo dico subito non è mia o comunque
l'estremizzazione satirica di l'idea un
altro grande genio jonathan swift che
nel 1729 per risolvere il problema della
sovrappopolazione soprattutto minorile
in irlanda con conseguente povertà disse
questi ragazzini poveri mangiamoci aveva
ragione jonathan swift mangiamoci
piccoli grandi mangiamoci con il
cannibalismo inc animalismo collettivo e
globale
noi porremo fine a tutte le
disuguaglianze di questo pianeta perché
voi direte no momento non siamo tutti
uguali ricchi poveri neri bianchi etero
omosessuali umanità e varia ma cosa ci
dicono sempre i nutrizionisti
appunto quello che da un punto di vista
sociale è una disuguaglianza
da un punto di vista alimentare una
ricchezza noi abbiamo bisogno di fibre
proteine grassi carboidrati quindi la
nostra alimentazione cannibale avrà
bisogno di ricchi poveri neri bianchi
omo etero degani mangiamoci vegani
[Musica]
perché io ci credo a quello che dico io
ci credo che il loro modo di mangiare
molto più buono più sano e più nutriente
del nostro e quindi la loro carne sarà
molto più buona più sana e più nutriente
di quella di qualunque altro essere
umano normale e cioè un libro mangiamoci
mangiamoci guardate che magnifico buffet
qui stasera mangiamoci noi dobbiamo per
abbattere le disuguaglianze
da un punto di vista satirico noi
dobbiamo smettere di guardarci a
giudicarci come persone e cominciare a
guardarci a giudicarci come cibo
buon appetito e grazie
[Musica]